(soft acoustic music)
- [Voiceover] This is
Sade, and this is Linah,
two young servals.
These slender, medium size cats
are native to sub-Saharan Africa,
and have a gorgeous golden
coat with black spots.
Servals have the longest legs
of any cat relative to body size.
Their ears are also impressively large,
and can rotate 180 degrees,
giving them a keen sense of hearing,
which helps them locate prey efficiently.
They're long, lean, and can
jump up to nine feet in the air,
to catch unsuspecting birds flying by.
Beyond birds, they mostly feed on rodents,
insects and reptiles.
Servals prefer wetlands and areas
with tall grasses near water.
Unfortunately, degradation
of these wetlands
is leaving them with less and less space,
while hunting for their prized coat
remains a big concern.
This is the serval.